okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
welcome to the second dead space for
dead space
my name is philip sham i'm joined by
rahman capazovilla creative director and
our audio director because today the
focus of the stream is on audio
the sound effects the music the
ambiances of the original dead space
were astounding it helped create an
environment that was super immersive for
the players and it was done extremely
successfully
a review today will explain how we're
leveraging the existing content to build
an even more immersive experience and
enhancing the content that was there in
the initial game
keep in mind that just like last time
everything that you're going to see
today is going to be
gyms it's work in progress so you're
going to see bugs you're going to see a
missing animation broken animation
art that's placeholder and that's all
normal so nothing is final nothing's
final okay we're showcasing content as
it goes in to make sure that we're
receiving feedback and we're able to
show you all the game and hear what you
think about what we're making
so this is the purpose and we want to
see interactions on boards afterwards so
hopefully we're going to be able to read
a lot of comments about audio following
the stream
today for the stream we're also lucky to
have one of our community council
members that's joining us so we have
jack patilla with us hey jack
thank you for joining
hey hey guys how you doing thank you so
much for having me today it's going to
be a lot of fun i'm very excited to
represent the community council for
those who don't know it's a it's a group
of people who have been huge dead space
fans for a long time and uh and we get a
yell at you guys and you can shape the
game as to how you know us hardcore dead
space fans might uh might want it you
know and i'm really really excited today
to see a final polished version of the
game you've been promising us for a long
time now so it's going to be it's going
to be cool to see it all working and 100
finished right thank you for your
contribution
you got the message right on
all right sorry nailed it
let's get this started uh with a first
look at uh the high level pillars cool
so hello everyone i'm really thrilled
and honored to represent the audio team
today
and have the opportunity to share with
you
some of the work in progress
as developer it's great to be able to
share that early with the community so
many thanks to everyone involved in
making this happening
special thanks to the azure team okay
we've got a group of talented and very
passionate designers and
as you will see with the upcoming
examples
they are really committed
to make that game an amazing and
immersive experience
nice to have you with us also uh jack
absolutely hey ollie real quick before
we get into it so you're the audio
director of the game so what exactly
does that mean does that mean like you
you're the one making the noises you're
you're you're playing the keyboards
you're making the squishy sounds and
recording it like like what is your role
exactly as audio director because that
could mean literally anything
making squeeze g's sound is always a
part of our background for sure but as
an azure director uh my role is more to
collaborate with rahman and phil and
also all the the the core leads and uh
working with the azure team too to make
sure that uh they
it's a facilitating role basically so to
help them being creative and making sure
that
they stay focused so that also of uh
work towards like a jira task and stuff
like that and making presentation also
and making them sound with your mouth
yeah always so live streaming is was
always part of your role no never
first
pretty green with that that's okay it's
going to be fine
so bad nice a part of our job jack is
also to
to help the team understand what we're
doing i call that the aussie
evangelization is to talk about as you
talk about what we can do
uh part of it is to look at our pillars
in the game
so before we start with the good the the
cool stuff i've always liked to see what
is our thought process behind that where
are we from that's real video game under
dude like it's powerpoint jira and stuff
so starting with the powerpoint it's our
daily job that's the real stuff always
because it's also something we that
comes back
regularly in our thought to say hey we
need to make sure that we stay focused
so how do we stay true to the original
game
and for us that mean always start from
there always look at the game first
before we start a chapter we played a
chapter for the original before we start
a feature we look at the original data
not only the data but also how it was
made behind
the hood under the hood or behind the
door depends but actually once you've
got that we put that in game the same
way it was in dead space and after that
yeah
that allow us to understand
what is the part that is working and
what are the parts that needs to be
modified to have a slight bodies to add
here and there as slight things
to make sure that we create the best
game possible
so always use the exact same foundation
and predefined soundscape but build on
it
nice nice
i i appreciate that too because i mean
obviously like there's a lot of dead
space fans out there that are are so
passionate about the original i love
that you're not just tossing it you're
like that is like that's the bible you
know you start there and then you work
on like how can we improve what we did
you know all those all those years ago
so uh yeah i appreciate that i know a
lot of other people do as well yeah the
soundscape of the escape the space is
very solid in the first place so we need
to make sure that we stick to it as much
as possible
so it's really uh cool so quickly let's
have a look at what we're going to look
at today we're going to look at four
feature of azu in that space we're going
to start on the technical side of thing
with what we call environmental as you
or how does the sounds is playing in 3d
around isaac
then we will have a quick glimpse at
isaac tools the dead space weapon
we're going to look at the alive system
the alive system is
the nonverbal reaction of isaac isaac
breeding his heartbeat and then finally
we're going to look at all of this
together
in game and ambient mood don't finish
with it i
i just got to say i love the fact that
it says ambiance over a severed hand
floating through space covered in blood
it's like you know like you go to like a
massage parlor or something it's like
you're like forest sounds a nice nature
sounds or the ocean and it's like no
this is severed hands is our is our
ambiance going on here that's you guys
have nailed it several ends go floating
in zero g
gets the tone right yeah yeah that's the
though and creepy singing so you know
that's that's gets you into the mood
immediately
all right let's start with sounds in
space
so sound in space what do we mean by
that just before we start uh obviously i
talked about the environment in treaty
it's also the distance filtering the
obstruction and the occlusion so jean
francois mike and ziego put together a
video that will explain and showcase our
approach to our towards environmentality
let's watch the video
hi everyone this is jeff trombley lead
sound designer and lead audio tech on
dead space remake
today we will be showing some of the
technical improvements we have made for
the remake
later in this video we will have mike
dominic technical sound designer and
diego mario senior as your
showing you in-game example comparing
between the s1 and the remake as well as
going over the technical implementation
behind the scene
but before going to the details i would
take a bit of time to go over some of
the basic audio concepts we will be
referring in this video
the occlusion is when a sound is behind
a wall
a door or a large object that completely
blocks the direct and reflected indirect
signals
in this example the sound cannot reach
the listener so we say that the sound is
completely occluded or blocked
in dead space most walls are tick mental
so if the sounds are outside the room
and the door is closed
so any exterior sounds would be silence
in other cases we will have glass
windows on which we can tell the system
to let through a little bit of the sound
so the result would be a muffled
filtered direct signal and a muffled
indirect diffused signal
for the obstruction the difference is
that some of the signal could
potentially reach the listener
in this example
the sound is behind an object or wall
but some indirect signal could reach the
listener by bending around the corners
of the object or by being reflected on
the walls
the result will be a muffled direct
signal and clear unfiltered indirect
signal
the portals
we refer to portals as volumes we place
on doors or placed at specific locations
in the levels
and at runtime the occlusion node made
by diego select the most logical portal
to play the sound from
along with sending the corrected
position it also sends the correct path
distance for the sound to reach the
listener the result is a more accurate
sound positioning and distance
attenuation and filtering
alright let's now listen to how these
concepts applies in the context of the
game
let's start with reminding ourselves
what the original dead space sounded
like
looking at the headbanger corridor you
can hear as soon as the door opens the
sound is coming from the right side of
the screen
the sound should realistically be
traveling down the corridor to isaac but
standing here you can actually hear the
sound coming through the wall
as we come around the corner you will
notice minimal audible changes to the
sound position and obstruction
in the remake there will be much more
noticeable mix changes when standing
here and the sound is not obstructed
to when i move around the corner and the
sound is actually blocked
now let's take a look at our in progress
remake
you can hear the sound is now coming
from the left at the end of the corridor
the orange boxes you are seeing are
portals replaced in the level and the
lines between them are the path the
sound is traveling to get to isaac
we lock the sound to a third of the
portal from the direction it is coming
from to keep the correct directionality
we also use this same system for sound
passing through to an attached room
[Music]
as the door closes we start applying mix
changes to the sound
when the door is fully closed we move
the sound source to the window and apply
even heavier mix changes
[Music]
[Music]
thanks
he could not see which way to go
if you did not
twinkle little star
like a diamond in the sky
[Music]
since this room has no window we are
cutting the sound completely as the door
closes
we have the ability to choose what
sounds are led through the doors so not
every sound will be called if we do not
want them to be
[Music]
[Music]
the system also works vertically
the way the system works is by creating
a map of the areas that are reachable by
the player considering the surrounding
openings like doors and windows
then when a new sound starts playing we
can check in the map we have previously
generated if the sound is audible and
what is the shortest path to isaac
we update this map at regular intervals
but much less often than the sound
senses because it's expensive and its
data does not change very often
but having this information allow us to
calculate a more physically accurate
position of the sound
[Music]
that that is so cool you guys i i don't
know if i don't know if uh i'd never
seen anything like that i mean i know i
played a whole lot of games before but
i've never really seen that those kind
of tools being used in a game i know
they probably have in some other games
but how important was it for you guys to
develop that tool for this base remake
well that was uh one of the first
discussion i think we had together as a
production to say
how do we make sure that uh
we've got a 3d audio that stands uh for
the current gen
platform so we really put a lot of
effort and a lot of focus on how does
the ozo back
inside the ishmaura and how we're going
to be able to filter that
to make sure that
one thing that is really important also
in terms of gameplay into dead space in
the experience it's the physical reality
of that world that the ishimura feels
like an actual place you have all those
physics based powers you can cut the
necromorph and all of those things needs
to feel real
and one thing we wanted to enhance an
audio was to give the same type of
approach to the physics of the actual
sounds and how they reverberate on the
in the ship etc to really make that
place uh
something living in which you can
believe
nice i thought man i'm i'm just excited
by like all of these new things going
into the game that i never thought of
before now uh i know like one thing
ollie so like when i hear a car drive
down the street i can always hear the
base of the car before anything else is
that something that you guys can do in
the game like with with this tool where
you can actually make it where like
certain frequencies hit you sooner
rather than later or like they travel
further than other frequencies yeah
we've got a choice for each sound or
group of sound to apply a certain value
to the obstruction in an occlusion as
mike mentioned in the video but also to
filter through distance differently
based on the frequency spectra
so we can apply a curve that will mimic
how sounds will be
influenced by the distance
so wait till you hear the leviathan
crawling in the depth of the ishimura
that's will be [ __ ] awesome
oh man i'm just i'm pumped to see
everything you guys are working on right
now and it's just like even even
something like i would never think about
that stuff about like the audio
occlusion and i know you know like is
that something like phil and roman is
that something you guys are working on
to use to like maybe manipulate a player
where like they hear something coming
from one side but they're actually being
attacked from another side like i know
like head fakes are always been a big
thing in dead space is that something
you guys are going to take advantage of
yeah definitely something that we want
to use to to
make the player believe something's
coming in a threat in certain direction
uh so so
it's more levers in our toolbox to make
sure that we're able to surprise the
player and catch them off guard
very very cool all right all right well
i'm i'm excited to see more what else we
got next
let's talk a bit about uh we mentioned
it at the beginning the the tools of
isaac because in dead space most of the
weapons are not necessarily classic
weapon
they are more like
tools
because isaac is an engineer is
basically using those tools to go
through his journey
so our main challenge here is how do we
keep the personality of the weapon of
the original but add distinctive detail
that will make
them those weapons feels like tools like
engineering
element
so
everything you will see right now it's
based on that train of thought we've got
two prototype once again it's prototype
we did collaborate with stefan and paul
from swedejust justice for this redesign
and both example you will first hear
dead space pawn original and then our
remodel prototype so if everyone is okay
with that so once again it's really
working progress for both for everything
visual vfx models especially animation
for the weapon it's early there's a lot
missing so
just a quick disclaimer
hello i'm michael dominick the technical
audio artist on dead space i will be
showing you the in progress plasma
cutter and pulse rifle today
let's get started with the plasma cutter
and have a listen to what we are
remaking
now let's have a listen to where we are
at with our updated version
when we are designing a weapon we
approach them in many different layers
all of the red and blue boxes outlined
in this picture represent another layer
that is being played on each shot of the
weapon
now let's take a listen to some of these
layers one at a time so we can really
hear each element that's being played
that's all we have for the plasma cutter
today but let's take a sneak peek at
comparing the original pulse rifle with
our in-progress version
oh don't hear you check yeah we're not
hearing jack
that's that's what what sorry guys i
apologize for that what does isaac have
against those walls he seems very upset
at those walls did they do something to
him or talk smack about his mom or
something he was hearing the necromorphs
on the other side because of
just being paranoid
just shoot a hole right through it no no
ali that's that's fascinating to me the
idea of so many layers of audio just for
one little sound bite uh is there ever a
point where it's like there's too much
audio like we have too many layers going
on right here or is it kind of just keep
throwing things at it i know it's
clearly a point
we always reach a moment where uh even
for a single feature like a weapon or
for the entire mix where the the amount
of frequency is too much in whatever or
the other so it's how do we mix together
uh all the frequent the free the audible
frequency spectrum of each element and
make sure that they uh have a purpose in
the overall uh view of the game so it's
about how do we mix your element
individually or at the granular level
but i'll do the interact with the world
that's that's cool and like it's
fascinating to me that like that the the
you know the plasma cutter all the
weapons will sound different based on
the location you're shooting them in
right
yeah because that's basically what we're
trying to do if you're in a big room you
will have like
not only the weapon but everything that
the weapon will cause
uh impact on the walls or impact on the
kramath to have the
reflection and the reverb of each
individual roots
that's cool and one thing i love that
you guys have done now you could really
tell in the layers was the fact that you
have the mechanical components of the
plasma cutter they're gonna hear like
that physical like the metal scratching
on metal and stuff as well as the kind
of more sci-fi like the pew pew type
noises and stuff as well and it's
because of that like think about that
usually you know you have to base
something on something else you kind of
get a reference point at some point it
what what do you have to reference is
there anything that exists on planet
earth that you could reference as a
plasma cutter that fires like bolts like
this or is it just something you just
made up
well it's obviously something that we
looked at at first we look at dead space
we try to isolate the iconic element of
the plasma cutter to make sure that it
still sounds like the original weapon
somehow but after that it's adding
element here and there uh obviously we
look at a lot at different tools all
those mechanical elements that make the
plasma cutter turn add those little
details here and there to make them
feels like they are mechanical they are
turning it's actually like creating
something we have a lot of discussion
and really serious design meetings about
thinking what how would it sound to
actually use a power drill in someone's
arms and what would be that sound and
that feeling so it's no it's a real a
real serious job you're like like bring
in the intern let's see what it sounds
like come on guys
that sounds horrifying now you know
you've talked about a couple times
throughout the stream here about going
back and using some of the material from
the very first game are you using actual
like sound files from the first game or
is everything being completely remade or
how does that work
our first uh idea there is always start
with the original so we dig and we did a
lot of archaeological search into
the game data but not only the game data
the backup that the team had at that
time we look at how they build stuff
we've got lots of original recording
original source so it's always to look
at both say what can we extract from
that because sometimes we don't have
everything we've got only the end result
and is the end result is uh what we need
necessarily or we need to
to look at redoing something that is
similar so it really depends of the
feature itself or
and the result of our of our our search
but it's also
it's a great way for us to have a solid
starting point that stays true to the
original and from there be able to see
and determine where do we want to
enhance the experience and and on the
audio it's the same thing that we're
doing
that's a one place i love the idea of
also using using archaeology like the
idea of like an archaeologist of video
games and you know wearing a fedora and
a bullwhip going through and pulling out
all the old files that's that's pretty
rad something you don't think about but
i guess you know i've got hard drives i
know around here that are you know
probably 10 years old that i don't know
what's on them so i imagine that was a
huge process with this
that was a fun process too because it's
always cool to see like hey okay you
find stuff sometimes you find gold when
you do that too you find things that you
didn't
know was still existing so it's really
an interesting process for sure
that's so cool all right so let's move
on actually to the next component uh ali
for the alive system so uh
we're gonna put ourselves in isaac boots
as i mentioned uh a live system is the
breeding of
isaac and his artbeat and we're going to
look at that with on a video with our
senior sound designer terry calico
my name is terry calico and i'm the
senior vo designer on dead space
in the original dead space isaac's
breathing and heartbeat was such an
integral part of the player's connection
with isaac in building immersion and
emphasizing the horror experience
breathing is a huge part of dead space
and horror films in general that enhance
the feeling of being alone and
vulnerable for dead space we're looking
back at the core functionality of the
original and not only bringing that
experience forward but we're finding
ways we can improve it to a level that
exceeds expectations in today's
generation of games
in the original dead space you would
hear isaac's breathing change and
heartbeat ramp up over time when
sprinting when low on health low on
oxygen during combat and spike for jump
scares or scripted events
all of that will be there
a couple of improvements for example
in the original when isaac was sprinting
or injured you would hear additional
grunts to emphasize his level of
exertion placed simultaneously over top
of the base breathing rate
exertions such as melee and stomp also
played over top of the breathing rather
than interrupt it
[Music]
if you listened carefully you were
hearing two voices at the same time
the exerted breaths didn't interject the
base breathing
for dead space we're building a system
that supports transitioning respiratory
rates through fatigued and low health
states seamlessly
as another example in the original when
isaac was gasping for air while running
out of oxygen exiting the vacuum of
space or using an oxygen refill would
instantaneously and unnaturally revert
isaac back to a calm breathing state as
if nothing had happened
for dead space you can expect to hear
isaac catch his breath as he recovers
from a lack of oxygen
let's have a listen to this prototype in
game with some placeholder content
[Music]
and as isaac catches his breath you hear
it transition back smoothly into the
base breathing cycle
for dead space we're building what is
called the alive system it encompasses
all components of isaac's breathing and
heart rate vocal exertions and dialogue
influenced by a variety of driving
gameplay features the limbic system is
the part of the brain that controls
behavioral and emotional responses such
as anxiety and fear
when you watch a horror movie or play a
scary game the limbic system can trigger
a release of adrenaline into the body
causing a physical response such as
increased heart rate
in our game adrenaline is derived from
various values driven by external
factors that have a direct influence on
isaac's heart rate bpm
external factors that act as adrenaline
are the combat difficulty value
scripted events and jump scares
isaac's fatigue level
isaac's oxygen level and isaac's health
we want isaac to reflect how anyone
would physically react in the scenario
he's placed in and vice versa use that
to influence the player to feel the same
response
for isaac's scripted dialogue lines
where the player maintains full control
of isaac we will have three variations
of each line to pick from based on his
current state
a normal version
a fatigued version
and an injured version
let's have a listen to how isaac's
fatigue level or being in a low health
state can impact isaac's scripted
dialogue in game
nicole
it's me
nicole
it's me
nicole it's me
making up isaac's vitals are his heart
rate respiratory rate oxygen level and
health
as isaac is 43 years old i studied
average heart and respiratory rates for
his age group at different levels of
fitness to land on isaac's base heart
rate of 70 bpm to build up from as heart
rate increases his respiratory rate
increases as well i broke down the
respiratory rates into seven breathing
cycles mapped out across seven
correlating heart rate bpm zones each
cycle also has fatigued and injured
modifiers
alright let's have a listen to how
isaac's breathing is behaving in game
one thing to note the breathing and
exertion samples that you'll be hearing
in game are not gunner right these are
placeholder samples that we recorded for
testing all of this functionality out in
game as we were building it
and here on screen is our alive monitor
this is some debug information that
we've put together to see isaac's
current breathing cycle his heart rate
what his breathing state is if he's
inhaling or exhaling what his fatigue
level is his oxygen level his health and
the current combat intensity
and if we have isaac's sprint here
over time you'll start to see his
fatigue level increase
and when isaac's fatigue level gets past
a certain threshold you'll start to hear
fatigued breaths exerted breath start to
mix in with this regular base breathing
rate
uh
and when isaac stops sprinting you'll
see his
fatigue levels start to go down his
heart rate will come down and his
respiratory rate will slow down as well
here we have isaac in a very low health
state he's injured and when he moves
around in this state we start to
introduce
little winces of pain mixed into his
breathing cycle
and what's really great about the way
we've built this system is that isaac
can be in both an injured state and
fatigue state at the same time so
hearing those injured winces those
fatigue breaths mixed in with his
regular breathing actually sounds quite
natural
[Music]
and wrapping up the alive system we have
exertions these are single one-off
exertion events that interrupt or
interject between base breathing loops
for example melee
stomp hit reactions and death
exertions for the most part will end in
exhales and restart the breathing loop
back up on an inhale however the
breathing system will have the
flexibility to have the option to start
the breathing loop back up on an exhale
or inhale depending on the content
thanks for listening i hope you enjoyed
this sneak peek into some of the things
we're doing with audio to make isaac
come alive
that is
wild the amount of work and thought to
go into you're developing a hypothalamus
for a video game character that's that's
incredible and i gotta say isaac should
probably maybe start the couch to 5k
program he needs to work on that that
stamina build up i think right there now
now ollie do you have any idea how many
uh like breaths are in this game
obviously there's different variations
of it but like how many inhale exhales
do you think have been recorded or are
going to be recorded for uh for dead
space yeah as terry mentioned in the
video uh
right now it's all temp asset that we
recorded uh but we're expecting uh
gunner to be out of breath anytime soon
because there's a lot of people actually
because he's in a really really good
shape the guy has
a real yeah that's a real challenge
who gets who gets to tell gunner that he
has to do three versions of every single
line of dialogue in the game does he
know that yet or is that something
you're going to be like here's the
script and the second version of the
script and the third version of the
script uh have fun see in a few days
that was part of the deal
yeah exactly
we're going to make him out of breath
when he's going to record he's going to
have fun on the mail
okay that's that's good man that's that
is wild like that that's stuff that you
never think about and it's one of those
things that when you guys do it in such
a high quality fashion it
you don't think about it it just feels
natural and you've done such a good job
with that so far and just this early
look so i can only imagine what it's
gonna be like when it's you know final
polish version of the game which we're
very close to right right chance we're
this almost done almost ready
not
yet it's still all pre-alpha and
and yeah there's still a lot of work
left but but it's heading in the right
direction that's for sure okay that's
absolutely i mean everything everything
that we've seen like you know i i've
been excited to see like the progress
that we've seen so from the community
team we've been watching this since
before announcement and just to see how
far it's made over the course of the
months we've been part of it has been
incredible and i'm psyched that you guys
are showing off some of the stuff that
we get to see early the larger community
because dead space fans are rabid and uh
any any little
like nugget of morsel we can get is very
exciting and so i'm psyched that you
guys are are sharing this with a with
the larger crowd
so
now what what do we got next what do we
got next i want to see more let's share
a bit more then a bit more then then
we're gonna go uh in game anytime soon
but just before we go in game
uh we're gonna quickly talk about uh one
of the elements that is super important
obviously for the entire dead space
experience
it's the music it provides a very
amazing
effect in dead space one the score from
jason graves
is amazing and it was well praised by
both critic and fan it use dark organic
orchestral music that dynamically change
at runtime based on gameplay parameters
super effective at setting up the mood
of being responsive to specific games
so for us i bring back the uh pillars
that we talked about from the beginning
to like demonstrate that they are
applied all over the place for us
what does it mean to be through to the
original it means
that we're going to reuse
both the way the music was playing but
also the original score
but once again as for all the other
feature we're looking for element that
we would like to add as a bonus as an
enhanced experience so for that we would
like the music of that space to evolve
with the narrative to change to support
the story and for that we're working
with our composer trevor geary kiss
and
fun fun fact we're just out of a
recording two weeks ago we did a cool
recording and we've got a little glimpse
for you
coming up
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
now
why are violins the scariest instruments
that exist like that's so free it's like
immediately your skin starts crawling
because it's like uh i don't like this
something's going on
oh there's clearly something about the
strings that makes uh this a bit creepy
right away that's for sure and the way
that has been used there uh
helped quite a lot but we've got other
uh tools in our back pocket to scare
people with music we've got plenty of
little things coming up
and i can't wait to see more of that and
i love the fact that you have different
elements of it so you can manipulate
that and you know play different things
at different times to really mess with
your brain that's that's very very cool
clearly what you just saw is
the string section but we've got also
like we can record a brass the perks
separately and after that it's the same
way as the weapon basically we record in
layers so we can play back in layers in
certain places you will hear only
certain elements and after that
dynamically
when the players are playing we put all
those things together and make them
fluctuated with the gameplay
that's so awesome okay well speaking of
putting everything together i think now
everyone wants to see
maybe some like game play like all of
this kind of squished together in in a
live demo perhaps is that something we
can do
i guess that's where we are now that's
definitely where we're gonna switch and
again the same old disclaimers right
everything's final jack that's it
100 final polish ready to go ready to
ship
everything that we're shooting again
today it's first pass in term of visuals
animation even lighting etc there's
still a long way to go before polishing
and finishing the game experience but
still we wanted to give you a glimpse at
where we are today and how do all those
elements we talk about today actually
converge together to participate to
enhance the dead space experience
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow that's
that's amazing i i i love it it's it's
so great i love watching developers do
play throughs because you guys do those
slow pans and look arounds that are very
dramatic and very very pretty or
meanwhile i'm gonna be playing the game
just running from spot to spot trying
not to get murdered so uh i i appreciate
that that looks that looks incredible
congratulations guys and uh
now we heard a whole lot of stuff going
on there i think i even heard like the
violins at one point do you know how
many layers of audio across gunfire and
like just the general creak of the ship
and music like how many layers of audio
can be playing at one time
oh there's a lot of layer that could
play at runtime and this is the magic of
dynamic mixing right there it's like
we establish as developer we establish
rule
in which like hey when those conditions
apply then certain things will change
dynamically at runtime so in the end
it's the player that will provide the
end result so we're trying to just
applying certain rules let's say like
when those conditions arrive then this
will lower uh 3db the music will rise a
certain amount so it depends really of
the gameplay there's a lot of layers so
we need we don't have the choice as i
explained earlier it's like the
frequency range is that wide and when
lots of frequency just add on it's
at one point it's too much so we need to
choose uh what uh where you put your
focus basically it depends on what's on
screen how close to the player there are
all those kind of things
man i i mean i imagine there's like a
lot of math in there too i never thought
math would be a big part of audio but i
guess so
it's it's absolutely incredible and just
the the way that all layers together and
the music and how it all cut it's just
it's so well done and it adds that adds
such a cool element to the game and uh
and it immediately just immerses you in
the whole thing and it's it's fantastic
and now just the idea of like that room
and the just the general noise of it
ollie do you go to sleep at night and
that's all you can hear like are you
just surrounding yourself with this kind
of audio like do you did you spend a lot
of time in submarines are you used to
this at this point yeah he hasn't been
sleeping since we started the project so
we didn't know but
uh no actually obviously we're
passionate about so there's something
that we always think about so we happen
many times that you hear a sound and say
that will be perfect for that feature
but that's
uh that's a part of our life and it's
really cool to have the chance to work
on that project that uh drive that
passion
really
all right well
everything i've heard so far sounds
fantastic
thank you very much like kudos to
everybody on the team in control and
everywhere in the world for for their
hard work still a long way to go but
definitely we we need to do a huge shout
out to the team we have uh a lot of
people that are extremely passionate in
the work uh and it shows uh when we're
starting to put all the pieces together
we only saw a glimpse of that work today
uh but there's a lot more coming and
it's actually something that i wanted to
say today that we're gonna do another
dev stream in just a couple weeks slash
months early may
we're going to do a follow-up to the
step stream uh with an art live stream
yeah i see your hand jack i'll get to
you
but just like we're going to do
our live stream in just a couple of
weeks early may uh where we're going to
have mike yazijan our art director
that's going to be with us uh having a
first look at art um and uh well i think
ollie's just set the bar pretty high so
great work ollie
and now i'll i'll get to your question
jack
uh hi i'm jack down here in austin i
know you guys are up there uh you said
like we're we're getting close can you
give us a general range maybe or as
close as you can get to like when when
we can get our hands on i know this is
the gold final version of the game we've
been watching now but like maybe the
final final version of the game when
you're ready to put it on shelves when
when can we see
dead space in our in our house the final
final final version of it uh so uh well
we want to make sure that we're we're in
a place where the game that we're going
to deliver is going to be um
delivering on the expectations of fans
and that's what's most important so
right now we'll say uh
early next year uh we we have a date in
mind uh we want to make sure that
everything converges for this um we
still have we're actually just a couple
weeks away from being able to do our
first full walkthrough of the game not
even on fire exactly we're still
pre-alpha
but we believe that we're going to be in
a solid position
to be able to do the proper polish the
proper debug and to meet the date that
we have in mind
but for now i'll say early next year
jack to your question
all right all right that's that's better
than some nebulous in the future so i
appreciate that
all right so well thank you jack thank
you ali thank you roman for
participating participating in that
stream thank you
thank you i i hope that you have enjoyed
what you saw today uh and uh everything
that we showcase please participate in
comments we want to see your thoughts we
want to see uh uh what we did right what
we did wrong hopefully not too much uh
and uh hear what you think about the
game and so
thanks a lot everyone and uh hope you
have a great fantastic day
you